we'll have time for questions but we ask
that you save them until after all the
speakers are finished then we'll have
time for a question and answer period so
next up will be Sean Carroll discussing
dark energy and Dark Matter thanks it's
a great to be here at yearly ko's and a
great pleasure to be talking about the
talk i'm going to give i was told talk
about science which i'm always happy to
do and particularly the remarkable story
of contemporary cosmology the
interesting news is that the last ten
years will go down in human history as
the time that we figured out what the
universe is made of this only happens
once but a thousand years from now we'll
be told that the end of the twentieth
century beginning of the twenty-first
century was the time when we got the
inventory of the ingredients of which
the universe is made we got it not only
in our imaginations but in the data and
here's the answer it's this nicely
colorful pie chart and the answer is
that us stuff like you and me and atoms
are only five percent of the total stuff
in the universe we call this stuff
ordinary matter and we mean not only you
and meaning gas and dust and planets and
stars and everything visible in the
universe and everything made of every
kind of particle that has ever been
discovered in any experiment ever done
here on earth five percent of the
universe twenty-five percent of the
universe is something called dark matter
it's a kind of particle is a kind of
particle that is dark we don't see it we
haven't yet detected it in any
experiment that we've done here on earth
but we know it's there from its
gravitational field it's something new
we need to find it directly seventy
percent of the universe today is
something called dark energy something
is even more mysterious and interesting
than dark matter it's not made of
particles it's a kind of energy that is
inherent in the fabric of empty space
itself so you can see the good news bad
news situation that we're in the good
news is we understand a lot about the
universe the bad
it makes no sense any one of you could
have done a better job at designing a
universe than this one so we so that's
great news for theoretical cosmologists
whose job it is to take this story that
the observers and experimenters have
given us and to try to make sense of its
full employment act for theoretical
cosmologists so let's put ourselves in
perspective here we live in a universe
that is big and getting bigger this is
an image taken by the Hubble Space
Telescope called the ultra deep field
this is what you get if you take the
Space Telescope and you pointed at a
part of the sky that as far as you know
is empty and you just let it sit there
and collecting photons for a long time
what it does is resolves into images of
individual galaxies and if i were a
braver speaker than i am i would just
put this picture up there remain silent
for 15 minutes and then we'd have
questions at the end because you can
just get a good impression of what the
universe is like just like staring at
this picture there are about a hundred
billion galaxies in our observable
universe each galaxy is a collection of
stars orbiting each other other under
their mutual gravitational pull we live
in one of those galaxies we live in the
Milky Way galaxy and it has about a
hundred billion stars in it every one of
these little blobs there is a galaxy
with approximately a hundred billion
stars the galaxy sort of like our own a
galaxy with its own stars its own
planets its own life forms its own
internet and so forth if you hear the
phrase the Internet's this refers to all
the different
and the universe is getting bigger the
galaxies are moving apart from each
other the amount of space in the
universe is increasing if you wind the
movie backwards everything was on top of
everything else 14 billion years ago in
a hot dense state that we call the Big
Bang and that represents the place past
list we don't know what the universe was
doing so a hundred billion stars in
every galaxy a hundred billion galaxies
in the universe the age of the universe
is a hundred billion if you measure it
in dog years I'm not going to say this
has anything about the relative
importance a--'s of dogs versus human
beings in the universe but that's the
only number you need to know a hundred
billion to understand the universe but
as good scientists we don't just look at
the picture and say that's pretty and we
like it we want to understand what's
going on we zoom in on the more
interesting parts of it here is an
interesting part of the universe called
the bullet cluster so not only do
individual stars orbit around each other
in galaxies but galaxies some of them
orbit around each other in clusters of
galaxies so this is an image taken by
the Jean Grey x-ray Observatory of x
rays coming from this cluster of
galaxies and I'm showing you pictures of
the NASA satellites that have taken a
lot of these spectacular images because
in the last year or two nASA has
canceled a whole huge array of planned
future astronomical missions so we need
to enjoy the pictures that we have from
the ones that have already been built
because we're not going to be getting
any more for a while what happens in a
cluster of galaxies is that most of the
ordinary matter most of the gas and dust
in hydrogen and helium is actually in
between the galaxies you couldn't see it
if you just had optical eyes but now
that astronomers have become Superman
and have x-ray vision they can find
where the ordinary matter is most of the
ordinary matters in between the galaxies
what happened in the bullet cluster is
that you have two collections of
galaxies there are some galaxies right
there there's some galaxies right there
two separate clusters and they collided
these two clusters of galaxies went
through each other in the galaxies were
just like flotsam on the top they went
right by but the hot gas and dust in
between the galaxies smacked into the
hot gas and dust in the other cluster
and was left in the middle
so you have almost all of the stuff in
these two clusters of galaxies stuck in
between and the galaxies moving apart so
you see the galaxies are over here the
galaxies are over there in between is
most of the stuff the ordinary matter in
the form of hot x-ray gas what we want
to know is where is most of the matter
in this cluster of galaxies is it this
hot x-ray gas like we would think it
might be or is it something else the way
to figure that out was given to us by
Time magazine's Person of the century
Albert Einstein because Einstein taught
us that gravity is caused by everything
and everything is affected by gravity so
even if you can't see something directly
you can detect that something is there
because if something is there it's going
to give rise to a gravitational field
and if it gives rise to a gravitational
field that field will act as a lens the
light that passes through gravitational
field will be deflected just as light is
deflected if it passes through a warped
piece of glass so we call this
gravitational lensing and the more
deflection you have the more stuff there
is so the technology has gotten to the
point now where you can see a cluster of
galaxies look at galaxies that are in
the background of that cluster see how
their images are distorted and from that
infer how much stuff is in the cluster
of galaxies and where it is and then you
can make pretty pictures of that and
here is the pretty picture of the bullet
cluster this is dark matter vision this
is an reconstruction of where most of
the stuff is in those two clusters that
make up the bullet cluster and what you
see is that the stuff the source of the
gravitational field in the bullet
cluster is not where the ordinary matter
is when these two clusters collided not
only did the galaxies pass right through
each other but most of the mass passed
right through the mass of the other
cluster it's something that is not made
of atoms and hydrogen and stars it is
something that we haven't yet detected
and we call that dark matter and we can
weigh how much it is the bullet cluster
is actually not the dynamically most
precise way of measuring the dark matter
it's just the prettiest picture that I
can show you many many many different
methods
us the same answer and that answer is
that there is five times as much dark
matter in the universe as there is
ordinary matter and that is not the end
of it the even more surprising fact is
that in between those clusters of
galaxies in the desolate cold of
intergalactic space there is energy
there there's something that we call
dark energy this is in the best NASA
tradition a false-color image of the
dark energy you take a little cubic
centimeter of space you move from
everything so there's no ordinary matter
there's no dark matter there's no
photons it's empty and you ask the
question how much energy is there in
that cubic centimeter of empty space
according to Einstein there's no reason
why the answer needs to be zero it's
some number it's some constant of nature
need to go out and measure it and we
think we have measured it and the answer
is 1 1 trillionth of an ERG how do you
know how do you know that this crazy
number comes from the energy density of
empty space if empty space has energy it
would do two things would make the
expansion of the universe accelerate not
only with galaxies be moving apart but
the rate of which they move apart would
grow we get faster and faster and it
contributes to the total curvature of
the whole universe so we go out there
and we look for these two phenomena the
first one you measure how fast galaxies
are moving away from us you do that by
looking for supernovae a certain kind of
supernova an exploding star happens once
per century per galaxy so you take your
least favorite graduate students and you
tell them to look at that galaxy in
every hundred years they find a super